so what is the best treatment for those
annoying eye floaters
that 70 of the population has
well it's a very simple and inexpensive
solution it actually is going to be free
but let me just first explain what an
eye floater is it's a strange little
worm-like
cobweb piece of something in your eye
that tends to float around especially if
you try to focus in on it
or when you look away now it's not
dangerous but it's just annoying
what it actually is is a piece of
collagen fiber
that creates a shadow in the back part
of the eye the retina
that gives you this image and this
usually comes from some type of
breakdown tissue in the inside of the
eye whether it's from
internal bleeding or some type of
inflammation
from white blood cells now ninety
percent of the time it's from
the aging process it could be from some
old
injury an infection or some blood sugar
situation because diabetics or
pre-diabetics
normally have a lot more eye floaters
than people who don't
because high blood sugars directly
affect the
eye it actually breaks down eye tissue
but regardless of all that
the solution is autophagy for those of
you that have been watching my
videos in my channel you know what this
is but if for those of you that are new
autophagy is a condition where your body
is recycling
old damaged protein so your body is
taking these old proteins
recycling them and making them into new
proteins
and the biggest thing that stimulates
this is
fasting so a combination of intermittent
fasting
and periodic prolonged fasting like
72 hours or even 48 hours every so often
would be the absolute best thing you can
do to help get rid of these floaters
now there's no studies on this that i
have found
but you might want to try it because not
only is it not expensive
it's actually free but you'll see a lot
of other benefits that go beyond just
getting rid of your
eye floaters so if you're new to my
channel i put a link down below of
exactly how to do this
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you
how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist your environment
much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today